so good morning everybody glad that
you're here and awake on a beautiful
Sunday morning we'll try to get the
buzzwords out of the way very quickly so
cyber crime apt threat intelligence but
you already have heard all the others
big data analytics and so forth what I'm
gonna talk about today is kind of the
ways that I use Python and folks like me
use Python on a daily basis for our for
our other jobs some of which is data
analysis and and other sorts of things
with a little bit different I think then
some of the other stuff that has been
here by way of introduction my
background I went to UT Dallas here
study statistics and a degree in in math
and computer science there with the
focus on statistics I work with a
project called the ml sec project for
machine learning with security so think
about firewall logs and think network
logs and so forth doing analytics with
that but on a daily basis what do we use
Python for well I do Incident Response
so your server gets broken into or
there's some sort of intrusion on your
company's network and we do that
investigation or threat intelligence
threat intelligence you can think of
like this if incident response is
investigating when something bad has
happened
threat intelligence is trying to go out
in advance of that and get as much
information on we can on who is doing
bad things on networks what sorts of bad
things how they do them that sort of
stuff I want to talk about that in a
little more detail the things that I do
not do anymore anyway not since a very
very long time ago hence all the gray
and the beard is I don't do application
Security's people talk about how do I
keep my web app secure there are folks
who specialized in that they're really
good at it and I'm not one of them red
teaming or pentesting or however you
want to call it we're just kind of
similar ideas let me you know get
authorization and then try to break into
your network and they tell you what the
weaknesses are also important not
challenging because
you know the real problem is that all
the networks distinct so where it's not
much of a hard work to be able to get in
there so instead what do we do well
today I'm going to talk about kind of
three basic tasks three basic areas that
that I focus on on a daily basis
investigating malware tracking bad guys
across the internet and analyzing
incidents for transients or we get a
little bit more to some of the
statistical stuff this is not a code
heavy talk this is kind of a survey if
you want some explanations of the sorts
of things that we do and why Python
matters and optionally why folks who
might be interested in this but don't
come from a security background are
actually in a really good position to
move into this field if if that's
something that that interest you so when
we talk about malware one of the first
things we do when you get you know some
indication you know whether it's from
antivirus or logs or something else that
there's some bad piece of code that's
going to do something malicious on your
system well one of the first things that
we do is triage right how bad is it what
does it do what are we looking at and
you did that a few different ways Python
tools are really really popular for this
I'm gonna talk about a few of them in a
second but the idea is you get some kind
of a fingerprint right like a
cryptographic hash or similar or some
other kinds of indicators and try to
compare that to kind of this other huge
known universe of malware here's a
secret that's really almost antivirus
does and most of them don't do it very
well right not that I mean I still have
it on my kids computer because they're
gonna inevitably saves me a lot of time
and trouble within the even the first
month of installing it but I ox are
indicators of compromised so now you go
past just what is in that file and what
does it do on the system you know how it
behaves or what sort of kind of kernel
artifacts you can find what sorts of
things does it do
how do you how does it behave what
addresses does it connect to what sorts
of user agents do you see going across
the network well you can imagine python
is really good for these sorts of things
so a tool that I've written
it's called mal Trev goes out and
fetches every time you run it let's say
every six hours or however a bunch of
malware currently being served on by
whatever kind of compromised or
malicious infrastructure is out there so
these there are these lists that are
constantly updated of watch out for this
URL it's serving a bad trojan PDF or
it's serving some kind of Trojan
application and so we pull those down
and then go store them off for for
storage and analysis into a tool maybe
something like VIPRE so VIPRE is a tool
for storing that malware and doing some
kind of basic analysis you can pull out
the samples that are interesting to you
and go do something deeper one of the
most popular tools for this is called
cuckoo sandbox it's an open so these are
all open-source tools that I'm talking
about here it's an open source tool that
essentially runs a heavily instrumented
Windows virtual machine so that as you
run a piece of malware in it then
they'll come back and tell you ok here
are the things that it did so you can go
have a sense of how bad it is and
whether maybe it's not malicious at all
and if it is what sorts of things does
it do and can we watch for on our
network and this is all dynamic stuff
this is all this doesn't require be able
to decompile code back to to assembly or
anything like that effectively if you
kind of know how your computer warehouse
systems work then at this point you have
a good sense of what you're what you're
doing with it go back real quick
there are other tools for those who want
to do that kind of static analysis where
you take a piece of code you're not
running it your decompiling it may be
you're looking at the different sections
within it if you're looking like let's
say at a Windows PE file or a Linux elf
file right these are the actual
executable file formats in these
operating systems and a lot of those
tools are written in Python because of
the fact that it's such a useful
language for somebody who may not have a
background in let's say computer science
or mathematics but understands their
problem domain and now they have an
easier way of being able to pull that
apart without having to delve into the
guts of something like C or C++ or
another kind of systems programming
language like that ok so I have this
piece of malware I understand what it's
doing I can go tell my network
administrators or whomever to watch out
for this that's all fine interesting
more interesting than that at least for
me is moving beyond kind of those real
technical IP addresses and cryptographic
hashes and things because those are easy
for the adversaries to change right it's
very easy to even in a programmatic
fashion spin up a new VPS to another
country registered new domain names and
so those sorts of of indicators have a
shelf life of about a day or two at tops
typically once they've used it for that
long then it's time to move on because
at that point defenses are catching up
and and watching for those things things
that are harder for them to change are
also harder for us to find and watch I
have a friend who who refers to what he
calls the pyramid of pain and he laughed
every time I say that I think of it like
a like a WWE you know two pieces of
malware enter one analyst leaves the
derivative fade but as you move up that
pyramid it becomes the idea is it
becomes more difficult for you to track
it and becomes more difficult also for
the adversary to change it so we have
what we call TTP's which are tactics
techniques and procedures which the idea
is it's how they do what they do it's
really easy to flip a bit and in your
compiled executable right it's really
easy to register a new IP address it's a
lot harder to change the
way that you go about doing your own
workflow whether your workflow is data
analysis or whether your workflow is
online fraud right so we enumerate
infrastructure we describe the methods
we do a little bit of attribution not
attribution a little bit of a hot topic
right now as anybody who watched the
Golden Globes knows write a lot of talk
about let's say was it really North
Korea that attacked Sony was it really
the Russians or the Chinese or this
organized crime group or the NSA or
whomever that did this and for the most
part that level of attribution doesn't
really matter because unless you have
handcuffs or cruise missiles or the
illegal ability to use them then maybe
you know identifying the specific
individual doesn't matter but if you can
instead say okay this looks like it's
activity from this group that we've kind
of identified we don't really know who
they are but we know that they've done
this set of intrusions now you have an
idea of what to look for based on their
playbook and how they go about doing
they're going about their activities
those sorts of things are important in
when we talk about attribution if you
can write a Python client that can deal
with a REST API then you are half way to
being able to be a pretty good threat
Intel analyst most of what I deal with
with Python are day to day I would say
about half of it maybe more than half is
really just calling somebody's api's and
using the data that comes back so that
instead of having to do it manually now
I can just script that across you know I
don't know a thousand domain addresses
and start looking for commonalities what
kind of commonalities do I mean passive
DNS is a little bit different than your
usual DNS normally you type in a name to
whatever client you're using right and
you get it results to an IP address well
that's fine and good but as we all know
right those IP addresses can change so
if I look up PI data org today it could
honestly end legit
be a different IP address than yesterday
or even an hour ago but what if I want
to know what that IP address was an hour
ago or conversely what names were
actually seen for a given IP address a
day ago or a month ago or a year ago
passive DNS just records DNS responses
sticks them into a database and in most
cases we then aggregate across a bunch
of different organizations that kind of
contribute data back it's not recording
data about the requester about the
client that asked it it's literally just
recording the DNS response so that then
I can say hey what IP address did PI
data org have on a certain day or what
names have ever been seen resolving to
this IP address now you can pivot on
those things that's what we talked about
enumerated infrastructure so you get a
piece of spam and that's been there's a
link and that link actually goes to
something malicious and now I want to
have a better idea of what other
possible malicious stuff is out there
that relates back to this same to the
same activity passive DNS is one way to
do that the other way is Whois data so
you look up the Whois record for a
domain just one domain and you have like
your administrative and your
organizational and your technical
contacts right so it says okay here's
the per the registrant here's the
contact information here's the name
server for it we can do two things one
is historical who is a lot of folks who
are engaging in some sort of online
fraud or what have you but tend to make
mistakes we call it oops Ecch right sort
of OPSEC is they make a mistake and and
will happen is this this is very very
common you know how when you register a
domain you can sign up for like one of
these privacy services right you pay an
extra I don't know five bucks a year or
whatever and with I go do who is look up
on back
guide.com all I see is you know privacy
protected through GoDaddy or Gandy net
net or whichever they used right well
historical Whois lets me see that who
has records before the current ones it's
really common that they accidentally
initially registered it with their real
name and address at the beginning you
think no no they would never be that
dumb yes I worked on a bunch of cases of
folks who got new shiny metal bracelets
because this was the mistake that they
made at first or at least that was the
break that enabled the folks who do have
that legal authority I talked about
earlier to go do that the other thing is
reverse who is so you've maybe even with
a fake email address that this doesn't
matter for this technique you say here
is the person who registered bad guy com
here's the email address used to
register it now show me all the other
domains that this same email address
registered well that's super powerful
right because unless they have a
different email address for every domain
and there are some groups that do that
and there are other things that you can
do but this is the basic idea then
suddenly you have this whole list of 200
domains used to steal your World of
Warcraft account or whatever as an
example of one that I've been working on
lately because I get irritated of the
spam myself if you can call these api's
now you can kind of see where something
even that's relatively simple
analytically right this is almost
kindergarten stuff in an analytic sense
you can pivot on these data so that
analysts who don't have you know thirty
years of programming background or
what-have-you are able to do some of
this initially I'm not going to go into
the details here the idea is there are
markup languages unfortunately Styx's
XML which is terrible you basically need
an X an F PhD in XML to understand it
Jason that's so XML is old and busted
JSON is a new hotness we all know we'll
move on but you have a number of
constructs in this it's called the
stroke
should threat information express in
language from it's one of these
federally funded research corporations
called this one's called mitre they do a
lot of work around security stuff
they're funded mostly through DHS so
it's weird there private corporation but
they get paid through our tax dollars I
don't know and they love to over
engineer stuff which is why this isn't
just XML it's a this whole gigantic tool
chain that is terrible to work with but
they have Python bindings so I stopped
caring about all of that stuff and so
what happens is in your database let's
say you use their Python money and say
here this object is a thread actor which
is kind of the buzzword or jargon just
for somebody who's doing something bad
right this is their TTP like I talked
about earlier the methodology the
tactics techniques and procedures these
are the indicators or observables and
observable is something that you can
actually see on a system or a network so
an IP address or a user agent or a
colonel named Colonel Locke like a mutex
right and now you store these things and
you pivot on them and this is where you
do some of this and now you have a
better database of what you're looking
for in terms of your adversaries of your
thread actors Varys now takes a step
back if sticks is kind of like those
crime databases that have reports of the
actual internet report and the
investigation and how it turned out
Varys is used for things like the the
national crime reports that you know the
FBI and state agencies put out
periodically so varis the vocabulary for
event recording and information sharing
something like that originally developed
by folks at Verizon where I used to work
a long time ago before I couldn't take
the evilness anymore and left what it
does is it describes this stuff there's
a little more to it the basic idea is
you have four things you have an a4
model so you have actor attribute action
and asset who did it what did they
affect how did they do it
what did they change on it so it was it
did they just make it unavailable did
they change the integrity of the data on
it whatever now
you could record this you know you have
enumerations with them so actors
obviously you can first break it up by
external for just internal which is
somebody who worked there or which is
somebody outside okay if there was
somebody outside
what kind of outside somebody was it
wasn't an activist was it organized
crime was it this could even be used to
record things that happen by accident so
an actor could include a squirrel that
took down a power line that took down a
data center right just by recording one
incident it doesn't matter but now this
is where we get to the okay so first you
get the Python my this is the only code
I'm going to show you this whole time
and this is just to show you that so a
friend of mine worked on this a
colleague and research collaborator and
and buddy and the idea was this is a
section of code where we took a couple
of public reports about alleged they're
supposed to be Chinese espionage
activity everything's China or at least
that's what some of these companies will
tell you anyway and we started to record
the attributes of it so this is kind of
what it looks like in in Python code and
now you build a front-end or whatever
and now you can enter this stuff and
that's boring and whatever but now we
get to I can't I have trouble calling it
data science when I was getting my
degree in statistics 20 years ago data
science was I got a degree in statistics
and with a minor in CS that's what they
call it now anyway all that aside the
idea was we did multi-dimensional
scaling technique so you have all these
different of dimensions of an incident
right and you pick up ones that you care
about and then you run an MDS algorithm
on it right so you can get a sense of
how much they cluster by different types
so we had we had selected a number of
different patterns if you will so
skimmers so you hear about you go to
your ATM or you go to pay their credit
card
restaurant and there's a little bitty
extra device on top of where your card
gets swiped because somebody has added
it this is what happened to Barnes and
Noble a couple years ago right happens
to gas stations all the time you know
they have the little tape across the
opening to the gas pump so you can see
it hasn't been messed with but that
doesn't really actually help the problem
because you go okay this happens here in
Dallas even all the time
there'll be an extra little piece of
hardware right on where you swipe your
card that when you put in your card and
take it back out to read the information
there's another piece of hunter that's
also reading at the same time and either
transmitting it back which when it comes
and picks it up later and boom this is
how a huge amount of credit card fraud
happens gas stations are terrible for
this there are other pattern types here
right so misuse point-of-sale loss and
theft because when you lose let's say
that you have a company laptop right
it's got a bunch of important internal
data customer data what have you it gets
lost that's a security incident in some
sense it's not necessarily an intrusion
but hey that data is out and available
to other people now it's interesting
that all of these patterns you can kind
of see how they flow a little bit right
this is the the axes here just because
they're just from MDS scaling they don't
reflect a particular human
understandable factor but this is just
to see where they cluster together
except for this green line over on the
left and those are the espionage
incidents we hear about the news
sometimes because they do differ a
little bit in how they get carried out
how they function this is from a project
that my friend Kevin Thompson and I
mentioned presented on last year at a
summit in Austin on digital forensics
attention a response and we did a whole
set of analyses engine techniques like
these too from a public data set called
the various community database where of
Lee their analysts and and grad students
whose professors forced them to do this
for credit can't go and categorize every
incident they can find that gets
publicly disclosed so you see in your
local news
paper the local grocery store got it had
an intrusion it gets published this is
where that shows up once we categorize
that we can go do all these other
analytics across these thousands of
incidents and that's a place again where
folks who have significant domain
expertise but not necessarily analytics
or not necessarily a deep mathematical
expertise could at least get started
based on the tool sets that are
available there are a ton of other
places that Python gets used in this
world right log analysis as you can
imagine is huge right building web
front-end so there are a lot of folks
like me and probably some of you who
just live in the command-line all the
time right I'm not right even within the
context of command-line interfaces my
interfaces then just tend to be terrible
you run a command you get it you get
some data back into a JSON file or a
Gamal file or whatever and I go work
with that that's not the most useful
when it comes to making these tools
available I don't the problem is this
there are a lot of folks including me
many years ago and probably some of you
who write tools for other people to use
to do their jobs
I write tools to help me and people like
me I guess do my own job better and more
effectively but because of that not
being a UI or UX expert by any stretch
of the imagination our our interfaces
are terrible bootstrap is like the best
thing that ever happened because at
least I can just spit out HTML that
doesn't look horrific
and is workable one of the other ways
Python gets used really heavily is in
forensics examinations so somebody comes
takes your computer makes a copy of the
disk it goes and looks for every
detailed operating system or file
artifact they can find and the folks who
do that sort of work also do a lot of
work in Python let me write a quick
script to go enumerate everything in my
Windows registry or what have you
Python again becomes useful here because
you seen the theme or
I folks who have domain expertise but
not necessary analytics expertise can do
this now then that data can come back
out and get used by analysts like us
this is where we kind of folks in this
room we tend to kind of have some of the
same level expertise and be able to pull
out now these better analytics to
understand these sorts of things that
we're seeing and how we can better
protect systems in the future and then
finally Python is really popular among
those offensive red team white hat folks
that I talked about at the beginning
right so that as you're breaking into
systems or you're testing these systems
or what have you then you're writing a
Python script to send that that exploit
code or to automate some tasks of moving
between systems if this is an area that
interest you maybe it is there you have
you may think you so for I don't know
that much about malware it doesn't
matter I don't know that much about pen
testing also doesn't matter you want to
some point pick up maybe a little bit of
that because it's you know we live in
the 21st century the same way the folks
who work in in my field need to pick up
some data analysis and coding skills but
the idea is that it is far easier for me
as a as a manager or as a senior analyst
to take somebody who is a developer and
data analyst and teach them what they
need to know about InfoSec than it is to
take an info set person and teach them
how to code way easier one way than the
other because reality is the principles
behind what we're dealing with are not
that complicated and in reality if a
programmer already knows how to use API
is that already understands how domains
and IPS work then she is halfway already
to understanding most of what we're
doing in terms of hunting threats across
the internet we're already there so just
because you see folks because we have
this honestly we had the same syndrome
so to speak in the InfoSec world and for
folks like me who kind of straddle both
it gets even worse
so you
I know this one thing and everybody else
around me knows all this other stuff
including what I know and the reality is
that there are expertise that that you
have that you have and that you have and
that you have that maybe we share little
bits of it but there's all these other
things that you bring that we don't
already have which is why this is such a
rich area for not just for for the
business because that's boring and
enterprise security is also the old and
busted Civic Society security is the new
hotness is also that you bring a
tremendous value in terms of what
research and modality research
modalities and methodologies you could
bring there with that said I'm happy to
take questions
Kairi talk about this stuff I like a
little bit of the the interactive stuff
I will be around the rest of the day to
if there's questions you have later